from the Chicago skyline follow the
southbound tracks for half an hour and
you will arrive at the latest
battleground in the us-china trade war
in this gleaming new hundred million
dollar manufacturing plant China's CR RC
is building the first of 800 passenger
rail cars for Chicago's elevated trains
but Congress is now considering banning
the company from making trains here
unfortunately
we along with some others are the
collateral damage of a much bigger issue
the trade war and the geopolitical
strife and issues that are going on
between China and the US these wires
meet the next potential casualties of
the trade war we want to be a part of
something special for Chicago and for
that to be taken away from us would be
disheartening and unfortunately we would
just have to find somewhere else to work
CR RC has 300 workers at our plant in
Massachusetts and plans to double the 90
here in Chicago but China has a major
image problem here with Donald Trump
sparking an economic battle with the
world's second largest economy the bill
to blacklist China from passenger rail
projects that receive federal funding
which is virtually all of them has drawn
support from both parties since Pullman
built its last car in 1968 no American
manufacturer makes passenger rail cars
the trade war launched by the Trump
administration aims in part at
increasing business and employment here
in the United States but mistrust
between the two countries is so great
that the u.s. seems intent on punishing
China even if it means also hurting jobs
and manufacturing here at home some
members of Congress fear China's growing
economic dominance and the national
security threat posed by what they claim
could be listening devices embedded in
rail cars critics call them spy trains
CRR C calls that ridiculous
CR RC
is not doing that when CRC builds the
rail cars and delivers them to the
Transit Authority CTA takes full control
of the rail cars economists say the
us-china conflict has begun to slow
trade generally there have been a number
of economic outlooks economic forecasts
that have said that the trade war is
beginning to drag on the global economy
generally trade is affecting global
growth in that threatens to derail not
just Chinese manufacturers and American
jobs but the global economy john Hendren
al-jazeera Chicago